let's start with the direct pollutants
lead used to be added to gasoline to
improve combustion in automotive engines
it reduced pre-ignition of the air fuel
mixture called NOC however lead is a
potent neurotoxin led emissions from
gasoline reduced the IQ of children
growing up in polluted cities this was
no minor effect lead levels were high
enough in the 1970s to reduce the
average IQ of Americans who grew up then
by five points lead pollution has been
greatly reduced to discouragement
regulations that banned its use in
gasoline and restricted use elsewhere
across the economy the average lead
levels in Americans blood has gone down
by more than a factor of 10 this is one
of the many examples where environmental
regulations have greatly improved human
welfare and have had a positive economic
benefit that greatly exceeded the direct
cost of imposing the regulation next
nitrogen oxides our atmosphere is mostly
diatomic nitrogen which is inert NOx and
other forms of reactive nitrogen are
formed by breaking the nitrogen bonds as
can happen in a combustion process where
oxygen reacts with atmospheric nitrogen
at high temperatures and pressures NOx
emissions can be reduced by altering the
combustion process or by cleaning up the
gases afterwards to remove the NOx
modern cars do both they subtly adjust
the combustion inside the piston to
reduce NOx formation and they use a
catalytic converter to change NOx back
into regular diatomic nitrogen
environmental regulations have driven
the widespread adoption of NOx reducing
technology which is succeeded in
reducing total NOx emissions even as
energy use has gone up but the success
is less dramatic than for land perhaps
because there are an enormous number of
different kinds of NOx emission sources
and the cost of controls is relatively
high
the US has reduced overall NOx emissions
by about 40 percent since 1980 sulfur
oxides differ from lead and NOx in that
they come from sulfur contained in the
fossil fuels as they are produced coal
gas and oil all contain significant
amounts of sulfur
when their extract
from the ground where significant can
mean about 1% or more sulfur by weight
the sulfur contained in these fuels is
admitted to the atmosphere as sulfur
oxides Sox when the fuels are burned Sox
converts to sulfuric acid in the
atmosphere with obvious negative
consequences for human health for
buildings and for natural ecosystems
damaged by acidic rain sulfur emissions
can be controlled by removing it from
the fuel before it's sent to the
consumer and or by using clean up
technology often called a scrubber
scrubbers for removing sulfur typically
work by using a base like calcium and
then making a waste product like calcium
sulfate which in some cases is sold as a
wallboard
in a clever piece of industrial ecology
in the United States typical Sox
concentrations have been reduced by
roughly a factor of five since 1980
other rich industrial economies have
also achieved deep reductions even China
now has strong enough emissions controls
that their sulfur emissions have begun
to decline in the last few years even
while energy use has skyrocketed the
difference between sources of NOx mostly
nitrogen from the air and Sox sulphur
from the fuel has important implications
for control if sulfur is removed from
fuels for example at the refinery one
can be sure that the final users of
those fuels drivers of cars or trucks
will not be emitting any sulfur one
cannot say the same about NOx as the
amount of NOx emitted depends on details
of the control technology in the
individual vehicle for example on how
well a car's catalytic converter is
working even a hydrogen combustion
engine would still produce NOx even
though the fuel has no nitrogen or
carbon the fact that control of NOx
depends on the operation of a myriad of
post combustion control devices makes
regulation and enforcement harder the
final direct pollutant carbon monoxide
is a product of incomplete combustion it
is made when fuels are burned without
quite enough oxygen as with NOx its
production can be reduced by altering
the combustion process and it can be
reduced by catalytic converters located
after the combustion source that oxidize
carbon monoxide back to carbon
oxide since 1980 the US has reduced
carbon monoxide concentrations by
roughly a factor of 6